Vô rào thông viên em của nó thông viên một thông báo, các giảm mười phần chăm số trình bây,
tài bún mươi xanh vài lớn trên tròn quốc, gió thiệu nhân sự, kiểm soát không liệu,
đây là hệ qua của việc chính phủ liện vang bước sẵn ngày thứ 3 mấy sau đóng gửa,
chuẩn ngày giả nhật trong lịch sử nâm ý, bố trưởng gió thông xin đóc phí cho biết,
đây là bệnh pháp hình cấp nhằm bảo đam ăn tròn hàng không,
sòn có thể được dự vỏ, nhiều phay dân chủ, đồng ý mở lại chính phủ.
Theo cơ quan hàng không liên vang FIA, việc cách giảm sẽ bắt đầu ở mức bún thông xin bây,
tăng liên mười phần chăm trong tần tự, anh hưởng tới các sinh vài trọng liệm,
như New York, Washington, Los Angeles, Chicago và Atta Lung Tà. FIA,
các cơ quan đang thiếu hương vang in nâm trăm kịp, sốt viên không liệu trong khi mười vang in người khác,
cùng nằm mình in nhận viên anh điểm xin bây bữa phải làm việc dưới ál tự cao,
mà không được trả lương. Các hát hào không lường, các bây hương vá phải hai chụi hình khác đã đi anh hưởng,
bởi tình chạm chắc, phí truyến và giữ gió ăn bỏ hả không đang ra tăng.
Trong bối cảnh đó, không hảnh truy phủ đón cờ tại Washington vẫn chưa có lối thoát.
FIA giên chủ yêu cầu ra hả cho cấp y tế trọng ở bộ mà kê, con tổng thử đón trông kêu gọi bại bỏ,
vụ điện sống mới phyều tại thượng viện để phẹ công hả có thể tự thùng quang and sách.
Dưới qua xanh nhận định, ý xưa gát từ ngày hả không và giữ lật có thể buộc hai đồng hoại sớm đặt được mục hả bất.